to cook or not to cook many people
decided to skip that part all together
and get their meals pre-made this year
cutting down time in the kitchen so more
time can be spent with family and
friends I don't really have the hope to
get the cooking started and cleaning
afterwards I don't have that hope so I'm
just not
just not doing it soon to be mom of four
Colleen and her family are celebrating
Christmas a little differently this year
opting for the pre-made meals as opposed
to making it all in-house the day of I
just feel like the moms have a lot of
responsibility and pressure put on them
to kind of get the holidays put together
so at this point cooking for the
holidays is just not my thing anymore
and Colleen isn't alone as more and more
people during the holiday season opt for
eating out or bringing takeout in
instead of making it themselves Steve
Whitcomb who's expecting a big turnout
this year says while a home-cooked meal
is ideal getting it pre-made and ready
to go the day of is the best option for
his family and it does take away from
how wonderful it was like when grandma
cooked you know and and the family
get-togethers but you know the amount of
work involved it takes away from the the
holiday it takes you know away from the
time that we can spend together when you
have somebody always in the kitchen but
of course there are those that stick to
tradition at all costs stating that part
of family time is cooking at home and
the cleanup afterwards I was raised in
Hawaii and family is everything over
there
I was cooking
for my whole family since I was a little
kid so
it just feels right to me and while the
parking lot here at this WinCo looks
quite full inside it's not real crowded
restaurants like Marie Callender's and
the Honey Baked Ham Company having an
influx of people coming out to pick up
Meals today with an even bigger
expectation set for Christmas Eve in
Henderson Madison Kimbrough 8 News Now